كشفت القناه الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه عن
وجود اشرطه فيديو بحوزه الاجهزه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه تظهر القائد العسكري لكتائب
القسام محمد الضيف بحاله صحيه جيده واضافت
القناه ان ذلك ياتي خلافا لتقديرات
المخابرات الاسرائيليه التي كانت تعتقد
انها اصيب بالشلل اثر محاولات فاشله سابقه
لاغتياله واوضحت القناه ان اشرطه فيديو
وصلت الى المنظومه الامنيه الاسرائيليه
مؤخرا ظهر فيها الضيف يمشي على قدميه
وقالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الجيش لم
يفاجا بالمعلومات التي اكدت ان محمد الضيف
بصحه جيده ويسير على قدميه هذا وقالت
صحيفه معاريف ان التسجيلات تظهر ان الوضع
الصحي لمحمد الضيف افضل بكثير مما قدرت
اسرائيل وانه قادر على التحرك بمفرده دون
استخدام كرسي متحرك وانه قادر على تحريك
يديه
ت